it's Halloween
you know what that means
all Sawtooth Jack is gonna rise from the
corn fields
It's gotta be stopped
killer be killed you've all heard the
stories
we failed at our duties and that black
dust destroyed our crops Our Lives it
must die
so we can live
your sacred duty is to take down
Sawtooth Jack before that church bell
rings at midnight you really think
that's real I saw it
it's real
you saw it
did you kill it
then let's go kill it
[Music]
you should do it you know I'm not
allowed just because your brother won
the run last year
I got an idea
if that thing isn't dead by midnight
this whole town is going straight to
hell
I want to go home I want to go home you
think you're special
why are you doing this
if you're born in this town
but first i'm ending this
tonight
it ain't over
[Music]